what's the most interesting piece of
feedback someone's ever given you a
director agent casting director it could
be positive negative but it always stuck
with you that's how I know there's
probably something way better than or
deeper than this but I I went from doing
theater my whole life to film and I
think my biggest thing going to camera
from stage was they're like you have you
actually like you have to be real and as
like I am real like I'm feeling this and
they're like yeah but you have to bring
it down and you have to understand that
every twitch every move every hair is
seen on camera it's right here so you
don't have to do this you just have to
be real so whatever you're feeling
they'll see it in your eyes
like you don't you don't have to make it
this huge dramatic process you can just
pretty much bring everything down and he
has human and as natural as possible and
I always I grew up acting in thinking
that I was being that and I was I just
knew how to portray it huge so one of my
first directors taught me it too I guess
that just literally realized that you
don't have to be doing these huge
jesters and stag leaps across the stage
to show an emotion you can just shrink
it down show it with your soul and with
your eyes I like that
shrink it down that's good I just I
think what anyone that ever did theater
and switch to film probably got the
exact I'm pretty sure but yeah that was
that one sticks with me because to this
day I'm like that the camera the cameras
right here and hit they remember that
they don't yeah they don't need they
don't need stag leaps across the stage
anymore
you